oh thank you so much for coming I'm so
excited to have you here if you could
just stop for telling me what you do and
how you got started doing this
interesting profession of yours
so my name is Justine and people know me
as the quote master a lot of people see
those amazing JPEGs that their friends
post on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook with inspirational quotes and
just amazingly design graphics I make
those that's amazing so what is your
information when coming up with new
quotes my inspiration comes from pretty
much anything mostly the tragedies in my
life and anything tragic I like to take
that and channel it and find a quote and
creates a graphic that really represents
what I'm feeling and what others will
feel when they post on Facebook one
thing though no thanks the designs I'm
not actually that say okay I actually
went to school should be a graphic
designer I have a multimedia degree I've
actually have a degree even in art
history and I basically went to schools
that I could learn what not to do when
creating my quote master creations we
basically take everything that you think
that you should know about typography
and throw it out the window we do the
complete opposite and it seems to be
working really really well for me and
the rest of my colleagues so you
mentioned your colleagues how many
people do you currently have working
with you
yeah I actually only have one employee
her name's EJ and when she's not busy
cutting or gluing or printing out
amazing inspirational quotes for me to
design around she is on the roof of the
office building holding solar panels
facing towards the Sun as the Sun shifts
she shifts with it and she's an amazing
worker because here we believe in going
green you want to talk about
inspirational right here we are an
inspiration and we love the environment
put that on your Facebook
my real question is where do you see
this going I mean to eventually going to
run out of quotes running out of quotes
yeah I don't think we actually will ever
run out of calls because even if we do
hit the wall with quotes we can reuse
them we just add a different background
change the font maybe even turn it sepia
and let me tell you what these people
eat it up eat it up what's the appeal of
these quotes to people when that posting
them on my facebook what is going
through their minds exactly I'm glad you
asked because this is basically the core
of our business model people have
trouble expressing their feelings so
with our quotes and these amazing things
that we have designed it gives people an
easy way to say what they want to say
without actually having to say it well
you say that they don't have to say it
but technically they are saying it just
publicly in a JPG forum there's this
phenomenon called subtweeting sub status
seeing if you will basically people want
to tell somebody something they're
friends with them on said social network
this way this person will think this
status is about them it's kind of like
that song not just think the song is
about you don't you
something along those lines they want to
get it out there they want to say it
with her too much above they'll say it
to the person's face so that's where we
come in we provide the vehicle to say it
just subtly stab that person in the
heart when they're down with a cute JPEG
I mean what other way is there I don't
think there is one that you do quotes
for all occasions oh is that a specific
one that may be high in a child senior
guys definitely our biggest download is
breakups now breakups suck but we have a
way for you to vent and to just make
your ex feel what you're feeling now
we're working on a new shade of red for
2014 to really just brighten up things
but yet let them know that you inside
are bleeding and
just a little stab cuz we've got him for
cheaters we've got them for every
everything that you might need we make
them here I quote masters do you design
a lot of them do what computer do you'd
roll them yeah I do a lot of hand drawn
images I will then scan it take it into
my computer and I will then trace at an
illustrator and I will make the highest
resolution image as possible use the
finest details and then I will rasterize
it and I will scale it down to an
extremely small little image and then I
will allow people to just scale it up
because we don't want to make it look
like we tried too hard but yet we want
to make it look like we tried just hard
enough put that on a quote and post it
on Twitter okay well thank you so much
for your interview uh I look forward to
posting some of your quotes on my
facebook so I'll see you soon
this is Samantha signing off thanks for
having me this was awesome I look
forward to talking to you again soon
what do you want one of my quotes to
take with you oh thank you fully